let's get some practice adding numbers
that involve hundreds so pause this
video and see if you can add these two
numbers see what you get
alright now let's work through this
together now there's many different ways
to add decimals and you'll learn more
systematic faster ways of doing it in
the future but I'll show you the few
ways that my brain might think about it
so one way to think about it is you
could say that this is 53 hundredths
you could read this as either five tens
and three hundredths or 53 hundredths so
you could say this is 53 hundredths
under its and to that you're going to
add 4242
hundredths and so if I have 53 of
something and I'm going to add 42 of
that same something to it what am I
going to get well what's 53 plus 42 well
in my head I say well 50 plus 40 is
ninety and three plus two is five so
it's going to be 9595 hundredths and if
I wanted to write that as a pure number
I would write that as zero point nine
five which I could read as ninety-five
hundreds hundreds or nine ten and five
hundredths now the other way we could
have thought about is we could have
broken these numbers up we could have
said that this first number is five
tenths plus three hundredths hundreds
and then the second number we could have
rewritten as four tenths plus two
hundredths we make sure my decimals plus
two hundredths and then we could have
separately added the tenth and the
hundreds so you have five tenths plus
four tenth so five tenths plus four
tenths and then you could separately add
three hundredths plus two hundredths so
three hundredths and a little trouble
saying that plus two hundreds and so
what do I get
well five tens and four tenths
we've done this in previous videos they
have five of something and I had four of
it that's going to be 9/10 so it's going
to be 9/10 and then the three hundreds
plus two hundred well that's going to be
five hundredths so plus 0.05 and then
9/10 plus five hundredths is going to be
and I'm saying hundredths kind of
strange is going to be nine tenths and
five hundredths which you could also say
as 95 hundredths
let's do another example one that's a
little bit more involved so let's say I
want to add 68 hundredths
233 hundredths
what is this going to be and like always
pause the video and see if you can
figure it out on your own well there's a
couple of ways to think about it one way
we could split up the 10th and the
hundreds actually let's do it that way
so if we could rewrite this first number
as six tenths plus eight hundredths and
the second number we could write as
three tenths plus three hundredths let
me do that in that orange color so three
tenths plus three plus 3 tenths plus
three hundreds and so if I add the so if
I add the six tenths and the three
tenths so let me just do that I'm going
to write every step here if you're doing
this in your head if you're doing this
on paper you would necessarily write
every step here so those are the tents
and then separately I'm going to add the
hundredths so plus eight hundredths plus
three hundredths plus three hundreds so
six tenths plus 3 tenths we've done this
in previous videos that's hopefully
pretty straightforward by this point if
it's not I encourage you to review some
of those earlier videos so that's going
to be nine tenths about six of something
and I add
give them in this case we're talking
about tens I'm going to get nine of them
so 9/10 and so what's this going to be
well you could view this as eight
hundred eight hundred plus 300 so I have
eight of something and I add three of
something that's going to get eleven of
that something 1100 so how do we write
1100 as a decimal well one way to write
it you could just view this as 0.1 one
this is 1100 many people would read this
as 1100 or you could view this as
equaling ten hundredths ten hundredths
plus one hundred hundred and ten
hundredths right over here is one tenth
so you could view this as one tenth and
100 so one tenth and 100 and when you
add everything together what you get
well you get nine tenths plus 1/10 plus
100 well now this is going to get
interesting still so let's see let me
rewrite this so it's going to be nine
tenths and this one let me write it plus
1/10 plus that one hundredth leftover so
plus that one hundred so what is this
going to be so 9/10 9/10 and one tenth
that's going to be nine tenths and one
tenth is going to be ten ten ten tenths
which is the same thing as one whole so
this is just going to be equal to one so
it's going to be one plus one hundredth
so it's going to be one and 100 and we
are done
as I keep mentioning in future videos
we're going to learn maybe faster ways
of doing this maybe way that you might
be able to do a little bit more
automatically but it's really important
to think about what we just went here
and how we were able to think okay 1100
is the same thing as 1/10 and one
hundredths and then taking that tenth
and then adding it to the nine tenths
that we are
and said hey that's a hole and in the
future we're going to be doing things
like carrying with decimals but this is
essentially what is happening underneath
conceptually it's really important did
you get a sense of that before you learn
the faster methods